I was in the midst of winding down for the day,
and my husband came in giving me a very specific look,
which could only mean one thing.
We were craving the same thing,
so we ended up at the Japanese barbecue.
If there's an all you can eat option,
that's always what we choose.
We tend to have the same cravings lately,
so this was perfect.
He ordered all the meat, and I ordered all the sides.
Obviously had to get shishito peppers,
some different cuts of beef.
I got this sushi with steak on top,
some kimchi, and then also these Chile edamame,
fried gyoza, smashed cucumber salad,
bacon chips, which lucky loves to eat.
I didn't realize how hungry I was
until we got in there and started eating. Look,
he's always in charge of grilling all the meat,
so he got started on that,
while I had some of that beef fried rice with shishito peppers.
This is so good.
I don't know what it is about shishito peppers.
We have to get them every time we eat out.
The sushi was really good as well,
but I love having fresh sides like cucumber salad and kimchi.
By this time, the meat was done grilling,
and I always get the first round, and he always gets the second.
I don't know what it is about kimchi,
but I've been on a real kimchi kick this pregnancy.
And combination of kimchi with beef and rice.
You guys It's so good.
We're done with all of the things that we ordered for the first round,
so we went in for seconds and got basically all the same things again.
It felt like we had an unlimited amount of rice that just kept coming.
So we had eight to nine balls of rice at this point.
Lucky was still going strong,
but I clocked out and ordered some mango mochi and green tea ice cream.
I always need something sweet after I eat,
but I also ended up having a few bites of his food after that.